defense secretary james madison's /
president Trump's decision to pull US
troops out of Syria but what if
president from Syria move is nothing
more than a border wall Bluff we will
analyze then Ruth Bader Ginsburg
left-wing Supreme Court justice
undergoes surgery to remove cancerous
growths from her lungs
what will the political fallout be
leftist agitators once again try to ruin
masterpiece cake shop owner Jack
Phillips his life and the top 5 moments
of 2018 on this the last episode of the
year I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
it's the last episode before Christmas
it's the last episode before the new
year so we're probably just wind and
down getting ready to see our families
sit around the table maybe go to
midnight mass right no right now we're
facing a possible government shutdown
the u.s. is pulling out of Syria
James Madison is resigning Mitch
McConnell may end the filibuster once
and for all in the Senate and Supreme
Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg left
wing far left justice is undergoing
surgery for cancerous growths on her
lungs this just a week after she said
her health is fine you knew this would
have to happen didn't show you thought
it would be a nice end of the year no
president Trump is the reality show
business president of course he's gonna
leave us on a cliffhanger we'll get to
all of it but first let's make a little
money honey
for the last time in 2018 with Prout
Alice you know Prout Alice with over 1
million happy pain-free customers and a
97% success rate prout Alice in Souls
have changed the footwear industry and
created a new level of expectation never
before seen for comfortable all day
shoes their technology has been proven
97% effective it's fabulous most people
don't know this that knee hip back even
upper body muscle tightness and other
issues can stem from improper alignment
well just down to your ankle now most
Footwear even very expensive quality
shoes offer minimal support where the
foot needs it most
they are just not engineered from a
medical or biomechanical perspective to
focus on alignment and this lack of
proper biomechanical support affects
your whole body other insoles including
custom print insoles focus on conforming
padding to your feet what makes portalis
unique and different than anything else
is they are actually engineered with the
intent to focus on the biomechanics of
your body what does all of that mean it
means that you were just gonna feel
better you're gonna be in better
alignment it is engineered support based
on body mechanics this holiday season my
listeners can save 20 bucks per pair on
any pro Talas insole at pro talus comm
when you enter podcast 20 a check out do
this I'm telling you it seems like a
minor thing you you're gonna buy them
you're going to feel much better it's
something you don't think about until
you do and then you will feel much
better I can attest to it plus shipping
is free if you buy two or more pairs
they will upgrade you to free expedited
chip
they have a 90 day money-back guarantee
you won't want to send them back nothing
to lose except the pain Pro Telus calm
promo code podcast 20 save twenty bucks
on any pair of pro talis insoles pretty
crazy into the year huh folks we've got
the most popular guy in the
administration quitting you've got major
change in foreign policy you've got all
of these crazy things happening how are
the mainstream media reporting it I'll
let them show you the walls are closing
in on Donald Trump as the walls close in
on Donald Trump he is going to be more
desperate the walls are closing in on
the Trump presidency I want to begin
with the walls really closing it the
walls are closing in the investigative
walls are closing in the walls are
really closing in the walls are closing
in walls are closing in the walls seem
to be closing in on using overusing my
cliches I hate overusing this metaphor
of the walls closing in I mean we've
been saying the walls are closing in for
two years but it feels like they're
actually closing right now and as the
walls start to close in on the president
as the walls close in he feels the walls
closing in the walls are closing in is
is the wrong image but but the the
bricks are sort of making the roof you
know buckle the definition of the walls
that's house again and if this president
feels as if the walls are closing in
tonight he's right because they are but
a boom boom boom boom boom it's almost
like they're all talking to each other
it's almost like they're all getting on
board with the same tired untrue talking
point the walls are not closing in he's
getting some bad news he's getting some
good news he's actually standing for
something that's what's that's what's
really happening you are getting a
dramatic climax to 2018 and it's not all
roses the Jim mattis resignation is a
big deal and it's a big blow to his
administration but the walls are not
closing in the walls are getting 10 feet
higher so why did James Madison this is
the biggest tough news for him he
resigned over Syria initially president
Trump came out and said James Madison's
retiring look at this point in an
administration two years in it would
make perfect sense for his first
Secretary of Defense to
retire too you know it's a tough job and
there is turnover
James Madison came out and said no no no
he didn't he didn't explicitly say this
but he released his resignation letter
and his resignation letter was both
respectful and brutal to Donald Trump he
basically implied that Donald Trump does
not share his world view of preserving
our system of alliances and of checking
power in the Middle East and of
intervening elsewhere so that we don't
need to deal with bad people at home
why does Syria matter why is Syria the
straw that broke the camel's back you
know James Madison had been reported
that he felt that he was in the
administration to be the adult in the
room and it was his duty to serve his
country so why would this cerium of just
pulling 2,000 troops out of Syria when
you've got another 5200 still in Iraq
why did this break the camel's back
Syria matters because of the Kurds if we
pull out of Syria the Kurdish forces
that are fighting there who are our
allies in the region are probably going
to be slaughtered by turkey I don't mean
to laugh it's just really dark
slaughtered by Turkey and and Bashar
Assad who's running ostensibly running
Syria this is really bad I mean this is
the strongest argument for keeping an
American military presence in Syria
Kurds the Kurdish forces are our allies
there and we don't want to look like
we're betraying them a lot of people in
the military community are saying it's
gonna feel like a betrayal if we pull
out fair enough now I think some
conservatives are taking criticism too
far beyond the question of the Kurds
they're taking and whether the Kurds can
withstand an assault from Turkey or
withstand an assault from Bashar Assad
some are taking it too far one of them
seems to be the president's biggest
television ally Fox and Friends
there was a very testy exchange this
morning between Brian Kilmeade and the
administration Sarah he's giving Russia
a big win Vladimir Putin praised him he
also is doing exactly what he criticized
President Obama for doing he said
President Obama is the founder of Isis
he just rebounded Isis because they got
30,000 men there and they're already
striking back with our foe would be
evacuation the president's got it he's
really on the griddle with this Brian
run III
have to respectfully and candidly
disagree with you the idea that the
president has had anything to do with
helping Isis really is absolutely being
is how rage using his help president has
put so much emphasis on rebuilding and
making sure we have the strongest
military on the face of the planet if
Isis wants to pick a fight with somebody
they sure as heck don't want to pick one
with Donald Trump because he will
destroy them and defeat them and he's
made that extremely clear we've wiped
out 99% of Isis in Syria the president
doesn't want to be in the middle of a
civil war in the Middle East and
continue to put American lives in a long
words we need to find a way to do that
all right Sarah thank you so much we
wish you a very Merry Christmas thank
you thank you so much for Christmas this
takes it pretty far to say that
President Trump is refounding Isis this
is a I mean there is legitimate
disagreement here on the question of
Syria obviously with our relationship
with certain forces on the ground and
whether or not it's in our interest to
oust Bashar Assad and whether our
military objective out there is to oust
Bashar Assad what we're doing in Syria
in the first place I had one person
describe it to me who said our actual
military goal is to prevent another 9/11
I saw there was an op-ed out today in
the Washington Post from Dan Crenshaw
which said we fight them over there so
that they don't come over here and fight
us fair enough that's actually the
strategic objective there can be fair
disagreement over what will accomplish
that but to say the president Trump
refounded Isis is taking it too far and
to suggest this is coming out of the
blue is also taking it too far
President Trump promised all along we'll
kill Isis and we will get out of Syria
we won't stay there unnecessarily here's
President Trump on the campaign trail
talking about Syria a very bad thing now
she talks tough she talks really tough
against against Putin and against Assad
she wants to fight for rebels there's
only one problem you don't even know who
the rebels are to say you're to I don't
knock Assad at all but Assad is killing
Isis Russia is killing Isis mr. Trump
let me repeat the question
if you were president what would you do
about Syria and the humanitarian crisis
in Aleppo and I want to remind you what
your running mate said he said
provocations by Russia need to be met
with American strength and that if
Russia continues to be involved in
airstrikes along with the Syrian
government forces of Assad the United
States of America should be prepared to
use military force to strike the
military targets of the Assad regime
okay he and I haven't spoken and I
disagree I disagree with you knock out
Isis he speaks pretty clearly there is
speaking in a way that contradicts
certain people around him certain more
established ideas and he's saying this
is what we're going to do in Syria but
the question is we talked yesterday
about Syria so I won't go into Syria
itself too much my thought on it is that
this is from a geostrategic standpoint
largely inconsequential I don't think
that this will have I don't think this
will rebound Isis I'm not sure that this
will be a wonderful win for America I
could be a blow to some of our allies it
could empower certain bad actors
slightly but let's not pretend that
we're pulling out of the Middle East
entirely we didn't have that many forces
in Syria to begin with we're only
talking about two thousand forces so why
Syria right now the actual answer is
that this is all about the border wall
and people are not talking about it we
will talk about it in one second but
first let's make just a little bit more
money this is the last money we're gonna
make in the new year so let's do it
we'll talk about brownells a big
proponent and supporter of the Second
Amendment they have been for nearly 80
years buying guns ammo and accessories
online is convenient and totally legal
you you notice now a lot of people are
getting much more into their second
Amendment rights and firearms people we
always think of just old stodgy dudes
and moustaches but now women younger
people urbanites are all taking an
interest in firearms and stealth
self-protection Brownells is the world's
leading supplier of firearms ammunition
firearm accessories reloading components
and more they offer an industry
exclusive guaranteed forever warranty on
all parts and accessories brenell's
offers nearly 120 thousand items from
new guns and ammo to nearly any gun port
imaginable Brownells has more than 5,500
partner FFL around the country makes
your online gun for
just go smoothly totally legal very
simple Reynolds's family-owned and
veteran operated has been doing business
in the country's heart man for nearly 80
years don't forget about the gun guy or
gun gal on your Christmas list
Brenda's gift cards make great stocking
stuffers especially if you want to send
a little Christmas present to little old
me you know you say Oh Michael I really
like the show let me do something good
for you by me gun gift cards from
Brownells go to brownells.com put some
freedom in your loved ones Christmas
don't you love me come on give me a
little Brownells gift card why Syria
right now this is all about the border
wall what is our budget in Syria the
budget in Syria is pretty substantial
it's over 15 billion dollars now if if
Syria two thousand troops there is
largely inconsequential what if this is
a bluff because it can go either way
President Trump talked about we're gonna
go kill Isis we're I'm gonna be there
longer than we have to but if it's 2,000
troops which you know we're not talking
about some overwhelming force of 30,000
or 40,000 troops what if this is a bluff
President Trump on the border wall has
no leverage with Chuck Schumer he has no
leverage with Nancy Pelosi
he has no leverage in this shutdown if
they shut down the government and they
say we're gonna shut down the government
we're gonna demand that you give us five
billion dollars for the border while
we're not gonna reopen it and they wait
they could wait into the new Congress
but what is going to be the lever that
actually triggers them to give the
funding especially once a Nancy Pelosi
takes the reins as the Speaker of the
House what if it's this Syria question
because the Democrats are in a very
tough spot right now Chuck Schumer in
particular is in a very tough spot he is
held captive by his left wing far left
activist base which will not tolerate
any money for border security they want
to abolish ice they want open borders
but we know that border security is very
popular among the American people the
majority of Americans want the border
wall the majority of Americans don't
want amnesty they don't want open
borders so the Democrats now have their
main guys who go out and canvass for
them who give the money who are
essentially their candidates who are now
their up-and-coming candidates and
you've got you're looking at national
elections and you think they're not
going to be able to win these elections
if they cater to that base this Syria
question might be a way to do it because
if they can go to their base and say
look we
didn't want to give them the money for
the wall but they were gonna take that
money out of the Syria budget we were
we're gonna be the adults we're not
going to let that awful petulant Trump
give up Syria and play into Vladimir
Putin's hand and abandon our allies that
we did the responsible thing they were
gonna get the border anyway and we
decided to save Syrians while we were at
it that actually might play that
actually might give Chuck Schumer and
out and it will look it this is not a
major campaign promise to pull 2,000
troops out of Syria if it were a huge
force then you could see how that would
really play in 2020 but if President
Trump can use that as leverage as a
bluff or not as a bluff whatever to
build that wall it is a big win because
he has to do it he has to build this
wall and Coulter has made this clear
mark meadows we've all been saying
you've got to put up on this issue or
you're not gonna have credibility in
2020 and right now by the way Mexico is
actually doing a better job of securing
our border then we are how how our dem
is going to be able to answer that Sarah
Sanders made this excellent point just
today what we have worked out what this
administration has been able to do in
conjunction with the Mexican government
and the massive and monumental moment
that took place yesterday where catch
and release has ended and it's a sad day
in America when the Mexican government
is doing more to protect the American
people than Senate Democrats I hope that
they will not let that be the case by
the end of the day and they will work
with us and work with the President and
Senate Republicans to get this done and
let everybody go home and let us start
building a wall and let us start
protecting our border absolutely right
it's really hard for Democrats to refute
nationally so what what is their answer
what do you how do you think the
Democrats are responding to those a very
simple obvious points they're calling
everybody a racist of course that's the
only thing that they can possibly do
here is a Senator Chris Murphy formerly
my senator Democrat from Connecticut
he said you you're starting to Marco
Rubio on Twitter he said you and Trump
are advocating putting up a wall on only
one border no wall for the country
filled with mostly white people with
Canada so now the Democrats are so
confused on this issue there
so broken up about it that now it seems
they're advocating for tools I thought
it was zero walls or two walls all or
nothing at all I get they must think
that we have an epidemic in this country
of three thousand Canadians per day
coming into our country and they're
bringing drugs they're bringing all of
those cheap socialist drugs with them
from their government health care system
is that what's happening no of course
it's incomparable now they have to make
it about race down there it's not about
race it's about crime it's about drugs
it's about depressing wages and it's
about the actual problem there are no
Canadians pouring over the border there
are 3,000 Latin American immigrants
illegally coming into the country every
single day so you build the wall there I
don't know should we build a wall along
our western shores so that Filipinos
don't illegally swim into this country
or the Chinese citizens - no of course
not that's not a problem that's a fake
problem and as we talked about
frequently the Democrats live in a
fantasy they live in a fantasy world and
this is a fantasy problem about fantasy
racism so looking at the new year
looking at the end of this year on
balance what happened
James Madison that's a big loss is a big
loss really because he has these great
quotes you know for I I don't mean he's
been a very able secretary defense he's
the most popular member of the Trump
administration there was a morning
consult poll that showed that he has 35
percent approval rating you know it's
not saying that that's a great number
that's kind of sad that that's the
highest approval rating but his
disapproval is only at 19 percent and
it's because most people most people
couldn't even tell you who the vice
president is so most people are not up
to date on who the cabinet secretaries
are but he was the most popular member
of the administration he said these
great quotes I mean when I think of
James Madison I just think of this
interview moment what keeps you awake at
night nothing I keep other people awake
at night you knew that he was just
working on that for years he just had
that one in the back of his head there
are other famous quotes of his he was
speaking to people in Iraq and he said
listen I please don't make me do this I
don't want to have to do this I really
want to help you but if I must I will
kill every last one of you he's a pretty
tough hombre
you know the monk warrior never got
married reads voraciously
this is this is a big loss it is a big
loss to lose James mattis not building
the wall would be a bigger loss it would
be much harder for President Trump it
would [ __ ] the administration if he
doesn't fight to get this wall built and
if President Trump thinks that the way
that he's gonna get this wall built is
by making a concession in Syria over
2,000 troops to have access to 15
billion dollars at the very least to
call the Senate to the table and make
them fund it or if not to actually be
able to fund it and that means you're
gonna lose your Secretary of Defense
that is a trade that President Trump has
to make he has to come through on the
wall his look he's come through one more
campaign promises than just about
anybody I was driving around and in uber
last night on my way to moral hago of
all places and the uber driver was this
woman she said you know I she had a very
thick Hispanic accent she said I didn't
vote for Trump but I really didn't like
Hillary and I thought they were both bad
but say what you will about Trump at
least he's honest so do you think he's
honest she goes yeah he keeps his
promises at least he keeps his promises
that Hillary is a liar she doesn't
she'll just say whatever people want to
hear but Trump keeps his promises
Trump's biggest promise is this wall
he's got to come through you got to make
a hard decision on that you got to lose
a really valuable player of the team so
be it what else we know that Democrats
know that they're in a bind here we know
that they're in this really tough
position as tough a position as the
Republicans are in and president Trump
is in right now let's not forget
Democrats are in a really tough one just
looking at the early 2020 field that's
shaping up you can see this it's a ton
of infighting a lot of racial infighting
you heard Kirsten Gillibrand say she
doesn't want to white men at the top of
the ticket there's this gender sexual
infighting it's all about identity
politics nothing really seems to unite
the Democrat Party there's there you
hear about the green New Deal
they've got the environmentalist left
you hear about certain law enforcement
anti law enforcement policies a little
bit on health care they can't really
agree on anything other than that they
hate Donald Trump but they're really
gonna have to answer for this
immigration thing it's bigger than the
Democrat Party and so they're they're
really caught on this issue and I hope
we drive this issue own I hope if need
be we've shut down the government and
humor has to has to deal with a party
that is split apart what is the most
darkly funny story of today we have to
get to this the New York Times has a
bombshell report out that Planned
Parenthood is accused of mistreating
pregnant employees now this should not
come as a surprise to anybody who has
any sense of humor whatsoever but this
is what they write quote employers that
champion women face accusations of
discriminating against their pregnant
workers showing how widespread the
problem is in American workplaces this
reminds me of this classic I think was
Fox Butterfield headline in The New York
Times that said crime rate continues to
fall despite prisons filling or prisons
continue to fill despite crime rate
falling now we would all assume if you
lock up more criminals the crime wave
rate will fall there is a causal
relationship here where the crazy left
wingers see a paradoxical relationship
or a contradiction that's the same thing
here you've got an organization that
exists singularly simply to end
pregnancies and kill babies and the
newer times is shocked that that agency
that that organization would not treat
pregnant women with respect they're
shocked this is such a contradiction to
them because they don't see the
contradiction and the paradox of
abortion it goes on they say Planned
Parenthood which has been accused of
sidelining ousting or otherwise
handicapping pregnant employees
according to interviews with more than a
dozen current or former employees the
organization exists to end pregnancies
they always say that 3 percent of their
services are abortion and everything
else is not abortion this is because
they count little nothings as services
so if you hand somebody a condom that's
a service if you kill a baby that's a
service and they give out a lot more
condoms or referrals to actual doctors
or whatever ninety-four percent of
Planned Parenthood's pregnancy related
services for abortion they are abortion
services in ninety four percent of cases
it's it's hard to arrive at a really
precise number with confidence because
Planned Parenthood does
actually admit the number of women who
go into their clinics every year who are
pregnant they can't admit it because the
reason you go to Planned Parenthood is
to get an abortion
so using various other statistics that
they've arrived at it seems that the
number of pregnancy services that are
related to abortion are 94 percent this
is almost all of them this story exposes
just one contradiction of abortion which
I want to talk about its if pregnancy
doesn't matter if pregnancy is just you
know it's like getting your appendix
inflamed then why does special treatment
of pregnant women matter so much if the
unborn baby is insignificant then why is
pregnancy so significant why is this
such a big issue we talk about pregnancy
leave maternity leave this is a national
issue Ivanka Trump tried to make this
into a national issue the New York Times
is making it into a national issue why
if the pregnancy is nothing if it's just
a little inconvenience that can be what
wiped away with no greater care than if
you're cutting your fingernails then why
is the pregnancy so significant doesn't
make a whole lot of sense
before we get to the biggest stories of
the year and a little Christmas story I
also got to talk about my old pal Jack
Phillips Jack Phillips the head of
masterpiece cake shop he is the guy who
was dragged into court the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission tried to ruin
his life because he wouldn't participate
in a gay wedding ceremony he's now back
in court for refusing to bake a cake for
a transgender identity switch party and
the argument here is not that he won't
sell cakes to anybody he's willing to
sell cakes to anybody but he won't
design with his artistic skill at his
own he won't put in his own art and
craft into participating in something
that he violates his religious views so
this is a total setup here it's by this
transgender woman who's a guy who thinks
that he's a woman named autumns Gardena
and it was the very day that the Supreme
Court agreed to hear Jack Phillips his
case because the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission was going after him so
unfairly the very day the Supreme Court
agreed to hear the case this guy Otto's
gardena called up and said he wanted a
cake that was blue on the outside and
pink on the inside
to be part of his gender transition
party Jack Phillips said no they've
dragged him to court again other news
right before we leave here Ginsberg and
Ruth Bader Ginsburg is in the hospital
Ruth Bader Ginsburg took that fall she
broke some ribs when she was asked about
her health just last week here's what
she said the question that probably oh I
don't know
70% of America wants to know the answer
to that would be the 70 percent who
offered you their body parts and organs
how's your health it's fine thank you
and those ribs you busted and almost
repaired that's good so her health is
apparently all fine she says and then we
find out she has just undergone surgery
to remove cancerous growths from her
lung she's now at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center one of the
best cancer centers in the world now
look what they're saying is that they
found two the cancerous growths because
she cracked her ribs so they went in
there to look at her ribs and they found
these cancerous growths and now she's
recovering from that we wish her well
wish her a speedy recovery but the
question is why didn't she make this
clear did she not know a week ago that
she was going to undergo surgery fairly
extensive surgery to remove cancerous
growths on her lung of all places not a
good place to find cancerous growths no
I think she probably knew that and
they're trying to play this very coyly
because this will be the most
significant event of 2019 I'm willing to
predict it now that's hard to predict
the future who knows you could have some
crazy war or awful attack or something
this nine nine out of ten chance this
will be the most significant event of
2019 or 2020 or 20 21 or 20 58
whenever Ruth Bader Ginsburg goes to her
eternal desert and arrests that that
will be the biggest issue that you know
this question because we've given so
much power over to the courts this
question of the Supreme Court is going
to be major you have president from
still in office that's why they're
ramping up talk of impeachment that's
why they're ramping up talk of
indictment if he is still in office and
he appoints an originalist judge to the
core
this will significantly swing the court
by replacing Scalia with Gorsuch nothing
changed by replacing Kennedy with
Kavanagh maybe nothing changed I mean it
could be a swing this his recent
decision of Planned Parenthood is not a
good sign
but it could be a swing to the right
slightly it could be a swing in favor of
originalism maybe not we don't know and
you saw what fight they put up there but
if we replace the most left-wing judge
on the court with an originalist you
could have riots in the streets you will
have riots in the streets this is going
to be the most significant event of 20
and 19 we have the top 5 most
significant events of 2018 we've boiled
them all down the news cycles are so
fast they're moving 24/7 that I've been
able to boil them down for you but
unfortunately you're only gonna be able
to get to that if you go to daily
wire.com I I do want to say also to
everyone who's watching it you're
listening and not just the subscribers
thank you very much it's been a
wonderful year it's been my pleasure to
be able to do this show every day and I
really appreciate all the tremendous
growth we've had on this show and it's
just really nice I appreciate you
subscribing to the show on iTunes and
giving us five stars and watching it on
YouTube and sending it around and
posting it I really really appreciate it
it helps keep the lights on except when
I'm in my boudoir here in Palm Beach
Florida on the road but it's just been a
blast we got a lot of great stuff
planned for 2019 I can't wait to see you
guys on the road at colleges and
universities and obviously every day on
this show if you're not on daily
wire.com though here's the rub go and
subscribe give us your money give us 10
bucks a month or $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the and
reclaim and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
mail bag you get to test questions in
the conversation you get to ask
questions backstage you get to you get
everything you've got another Kingdom a
major show lots of great reviews on
another Kingdom and you and you'll will
be getting season 3 hopefully coming out
sometime next year none of that matters
what really matters is the leftist years
tumblr if we shut down the government
and if President Trump backs Democrats
into a quarter here we're there they're
willing to actually come to the table
over the Syria question cuz he's gonna
have the money or he's not gonna have
the money
you're a leftist here's tumblr it's not
going to be enough you actually will
need to go and subscribe I've estimated
fifteen times you're gonna need to buy
15 daily wire subscriptions per person
just to be able to collect all of these
salty salty snowflakes because it's more
voluminous that when when left us tears
freeze they increase in volume and that
this can really crush you under the
weight of an avalanche so go to daily
wire calm we'll be right back with the
top 5 moments of 2018 and a Christmas
political sign-off message before the
new year
the top five moments of 2018 I got to
tell you when I was looking at these
moments I was trying to think back on
all of the events this year the news
cycle is so fast right now I couldn't
even remember them
the Cavanaugh confirmation seems like it
was years ago the the Michael Cohen
stuff the John McCain all of these
things everything that's happened this
year seems so long ago because the news
cycle is so frantic even this government
shutdown debate which has been going on
for a matter of days is it feels like
we've been here for two months so what
are the top five moments I I will give
them to you in this order from least
consequential to most consequential
number five the sentencing of Michael
Cohen for campaign finance violations
doesn't seem like maybe a question of
huge political import it is it really
matters because that when the they
sentenced Michael Cohen they went after
the president's personal lawyer kick in
his door take his files you know run
roughshod over his office ostensibly
that was for the Russia probe the probe
into Russian interference in the
election okay that's ostensibly the
purpose of the special counsel now this
whole investigation was rotten from the
beginning it was used as an excuse to
spy on the Trump campaign it involved
bought and paid for a Democrat research
to spur it that was not verified at the
time huge FISA abuse totally weak
applications it was it was rotten from
the beginning but at least you could
understand the narrative the narrative
was Russia interfered in the election we
alleged the president Trump committed
crimes with Russia in the course of that
interference and we're going to
investigate it okay I get that
so Michael Cohen is gonna go to jail is
gonna go rot in prison for campaign
finance violations well now I'm kind of
what does that have to do with Russia
that doesn't have anything to do with
Russia that has to do with porn stars
that has to do with his work at the
Trump Organization what on earth does
that have to do with Russia it doesn't
but what it exposes is that this Muller
investigation and the Southern District
of New York now is simply trying to end
the Trump presidency they are simply
trying to overturn the 2016 presidential
election and if they can't do it if they
can't Alstom from office they're gonna
make him so toxic that no one's gonna be
able to elect him in 2020 that is their
mission that's what they're after they
don't care about Russia they don't care
about Vladimir Putin they don't care
about boris and Natasha they care about
asking President Trump from office the
sentencing of Michael Cohen showed that
once and for all the fact that we're
talking about campaign finance with
regard to the Special Counsel probe is
on its face absurd now you're gonna see
this only heat up in the new year I mean
at least now the blinders are off we
don't have to think that this is some
fair investigation but it is going to
get ugly Bob Muller is saying that they
could have a report by mid-february or
that's at least that's the reporting
that's coming out now we'll see we've
heard this before it was supposed to end
in September then I was supposed to end
in November then it didn't happen that's
number five number for the deaths of
John McCain and George HW Bush most
consequential number for the reason for
this is not because it was so shocking
we all knew John McCain was dying and we
all knew that George Bush was dying very
George Bush was very old John McCain was
no spring chicken either the reason that
it was consequential is it showed the
depths of degradation to which the
mainstream media will subject themselves
just to attack in incumbent sitting
Republican politicians during John
McCain's life whenever he posed a threat
to a Democrat the media were vicious
against him they were brutal to him
George Bush the same thing he was out of
touch his wife was ugly he cheated on
all of these things with no evidence of
that that they would throw it at
President Bush he was all it was he
didn't care about people he didn't know
how to use a grocery scanner read all of
these canards and then when he dies all
those were the good old days
oh those I have a strange new respect
for George Bush that's what they all say
because I hate Trump and it's BS and
guess what even Donald Trump who is an
extreme personality even Donald Trump
when we get twenty years down the line
and we've got some other Republican in
office they're gonna say that guy's
Hitler and Donald Trump those were the
good old days that's what you're gonna
hear they're gonna give him the Nixon
treatment they're going to give him the
Reagan treatment it was so they turned
the John McCain funeral especially into
a spectacle an anti-trump spectacle
and it just showed how shallow it is
because these guys would have good lives
both were war heroes John McCain and
George HW Bush George Bush such a model
father grandfather statesman he held all
of these offices
CIA director vice pres president and
they tried to shrink his life and make
it a referendum on Donald Trump and
juxtapose it with Donald Trump and it
was really sad and it should again take
the peel back the the layers and the
facades and realize that they just
despise Republicans and conservatives
and you're not going to get them to like
you you know you're not John McCain
we'll always tried to get the New York
Times to like him and they liked him
when he doesn't pose a threat and then
when he did they would ditch him they
would stab him right in the back don't
do it don't try to say oh I'm a
Republican but I'm not that kind of
Republican on Republican but I hate
Donald Trump really like me like me
mainstream media it is pointless they
will go after you they will use you they
will abuse you shamelessly number three
most consequential event of 2018 the
banning of Jesse Kelly from Twitter
again you don't think that this is of
geopolitical importance it really is
Jesse Kelly he's an Iraq war veteran
he's a congressional candidate he's a
radio host totally mainstream guy and
big tech censored him they banned him
without any reason from Twitter they
didn't give any explanation they
couldn't show what rules he violated and
they banned him from Twitter the uproar
the outrage was so great that eventually
they had to reinstate him it was just
too absurd but they're coming after us
the reason this is one of the most
consequential events is because tech
censorship has been creeping along the
whole year you saw this in Google's
firing of James d'amour you saw this in
the banning of Alex Jones from social
media platforms you saw this in the deep
platforming of Gavin McGinnis the
conservative comedian oh and Benjamin
another comedian on and on you see it
constantly going down this path and
people would always say well it's Alex
Jones he's a shirtless vitamin salesman
oh who cares about
oh well Gavin he shouldn't have said
that oh and Benjamin he took that joke
too far he's just but then you get to
Jesse Kelly and you realize no those
were all just test shots they're really
just going after conservatives they
think conservative ideas are hateful
they now think that it's hateful to say
that a man is not a woman there was
a feminist author in Canada who said a
man is not a woman she's an editor of a
feminist Journal she's now blocked from
Twitter she's banned I can't you can't
go follow her she's gone
that this is a big deal because it's
going to raise big questions about how
conservatives should fight big tech it's
going to raise some questions as to
whether we should use the government to
do it as to whether we should regulate
them as publishers as to whether we can
if it would even be possible to build
our own platforms because the issue is
if they kick you off of I don't know
Twitter you can go somewhere else and
maybe you've got to raise money on
patreon okay what if patreon kicks you
off these crowdfunding platforms
GoFundMe well then you're then you're in
hot water what if what if they don't
kick you off but then the leftist mob is
so great that they get the payment
processors to refuse to do business to
pay you your money what about that how
far down the line does this go
do we need to wield the power of the
state here do we need to find some other
way to subvert the industry this is
going to be a dominant theme in 2019 the
number-two most consequential event of
the year I'll let Kanye show it to you
himself this question here in the Oval
Office okay how does it feel to be in
the Oval Office oh it is good energy in
there is a good energy it's good it's a
great place the problem is illegal guns
illegal guns is the problem not not
legal guns we have the right to bear
arms
you know I love you
take I don't want to put you in that
spot not standing in that spot I love
this guy right here let me get to sky
yeah it is really nice that's good why
is this a mascot most people thought
this was a circus
they said that why would this be a
consequential event it is because it
showed the President Trump is a unique
candidate what was the last Republican
who was able to connect with the biggest
pop store in the world who is the way
it's really about pop culture
most people just view the Kanye Oval
Office meaning through the lens of race
and that does matter because president
Trump's approval rating among black
voters has increased dramatically it's
really very high for a Republican
politician so that is great to you so
Candace Owens I just saw her last night
she's leading the black suit movement
the black exit from the Democrat Party
and there there is this idea that's
floating around which is that if there
is a race of people who are voting
uniformly with one political party
something has gone seriously wrong
because you look at other races here the
Italians for instance the Italians come
to America and they don't all vote in
bloc you've got Nancy Pelosi is Italian
andrew Cuomo Chris Cuomo is Italian I'm
Italian - Anthony scaramouche is Italian
you've got other conservatives you got
left wingers you got the whole spectrum
same thing with the Irish you got really
conservative Irishmen then you got the
Irish Democrats and yet with black
voters they are voting or have voted
historically uniformly Democrat and a
little bit of that began to crack but I
think what's even more important about
that Kanye meeting is the pop culture of
it all Kanye West is the biggest pop
culture star in the world on planet
Earth other than Donald Trump and Donald
Trump has used the culture in his
campaign obviously in his entire career
but in his campaign and his in his
presidency he's created an exuberance
he's used humor constantly finally
conservatives are the ones who can laugh
who can tell jokes who are the cool guys
and the left wingers are the mean old
skulls this is really important it's
really helpful it really helps people to
connect to politicians I hope look
Donald Trump is a unique figure he's an
American original but I hope
conservatives can try to take that
spirit and bring it in with their other
politicians and the number-one most
consequential event of 2018 I like beer
I liked beer I still like beer had
have some beers one beer drink beer
drinks beer drank beer and drinking beer
you've probably had beer center each
week Ralph's Club biggest contributor
you know I got a weak stomach whether
it's with beer I like you here for that
I like beer I don't know if you'd okay
like beer senator um what do you like to
do next one hanging out and having some
beers with friends which I gladly do I
like beer I like beer what can I title
do like beer this is the most
consequential event of the year it's not
just the Cavanaugh confirmation it's
Brett Kavanaugh fighting back and it's
the Republican presidents standing by
his choice virtually any other
Republican president would have caved
would have withdrawn his nomination
maybe any other Supreme Court nominee
would not have gone out there and fought
and he went out there and fought and he
used the culture and he made fun of
those senators and they said they tried
to make this imagine living so
squeaky-clean a life that the worst
thing you ever did was drink beer in
high school
imagine you would be you you would get a
straight shot up to heaven do not stay
in purgatory do not stay there for a
thousand years go straight to heaven
this guy he has to defend himself for
drinking beer in high school what does
he do does he say I'm sorry I shouldn't
have had a beer in high school no he
went right in their face and he said
yeah I liked beer and you know I still
like beer and hey senator have you ever
had a beer when you were 18 did you
maybe have a beer or two and obviously
they over there the scolds now Sheldon
Whitehouse wrong we're not rob la okay I
love that he fought back this was a big
issue they said he has to be more
judicial well then the Senate should be
senatorial he has to be more civil yeah
then his inquisitors should be civil -
and if they're not gonna be civil who
cares why on earth would he play by
rules that they won't play by we're in a
brawl here folks we're in a political
brawl and he shouldn't be expected to be
playing by all of these beautiful rules
while they're gonna go out there and
Shiv him right in the gut it's
ridiculous and he came out and fought
and they got him through and this was so
important it was important to
Republicans doing as well as they did in
the midterm elections it was important
to feeling that elections do have
consequences a really beautiful moment
the most consequential end if God forbid
anything happens to Justice Ginsburg
2019 is going to make that look like a
cakewalk Oh
before we leave here for the break
before Christmas of New Year's I do want
a little Christmas rundown there's a new
NPR PBS Newshour Marist Poll out which
found that adults under the age of 30 or
the only age group that prefers to pay
for Christmas gifts on credit cards
they're the only age group that strongly
prefers to say Happy Holidays to Merry
Christmas and they're the only age group
which loves Christmas trees but wants
fake Christmas trees they prefer fake
Christmas trees talk about the war on
Christmas this is a new flank the
Millennials coming in and attacking
Christmas this poll should be
unsurprising this poll describes exactly
what we would expect of Millennials
Millennials as as the left broadly does
they want the appearance of the thing
but they don't want the essence of the
thing they want the appearance of
whatever they're talking about but they
don't want to do what actually makes
that thing that thing so even with the
paying they want to pay on credit card
rather than cash I do too I pay for
almost everything on credit card but
what is cash cash is a symbol right cash
is a symbol of Labor of productivity of
trust in a system and so cash itself is
a symbol and credit cards are a symbol
of a symbol credit cards are one step
removed from that you use that to count
dollars and cents but really it's just a
symbol I'm chords they prefer happy
holidays - Merry Christmas what does
happy holidays refer to it refers to
Christmas doesn't refer to Hanukkah
Hanukkah has been over for weeks
it doesn't refer to the new year that's
in the new year it doesn't refer to
Thanksgiving it doesn't refer to Arbor
Day refers to Christmas but they and
they want that Christmas feeling but
they don't want it to be Christmas they
want to call it something else happy
holidays and same thing with the tree
they want the tree they want all the
stuff this stuff is really nice but they
don't want the thing that makes the tree
the tree which is the tree they want a
fake tree they want a bunch of plastic
and maybe it'll spray some fake
Christmas tree smell on it they don't
want the real thing they probably drink
decaf coffee - a classic millennial
story and also just a little inspiration
for Christmas we all know the real story
of Christmas the Incarnation the birth
of Christ how wonderful I want to tell
one side story about Christmas then we
can meditate on the Incarnation and the
greatest event in the history of the
world top tide I suppose our own only
second to the resurrection
at the Council of Nicaea picture it ad
325 you've got there st. nicholas of
myra st. jolly old st. nicholas and
you've got a heretic arias arias who's a
heretical christian who denies the
divinity of christ and they're there
they're debating they're being really
civil they're being really collegial and
then area spouts as heresy denies the
divinity of christ and jolly old st.
nicholas Santa Claus himself gets so
irritated that he gets up and he punches
that heretic right in the face now did
this story really happen it's unclear
there is some dispute in the historical
record it's certainly in the tradition
in eastern Christian iconography you see
it all the time the image of Saint
Nicholas slapping arias across the face
the story has changed a little bit over
time it was initially that st. Nicholas
slapped an Arian a follower of areas but
not areas himself and then in the
earliest texts we have from the Council
of Nicaea there's really no evidence
that st. Nicholas even was there but
this story has endured for millennia now
so I I like it nonetheless it clearly
has some explanatory power which is we
are told that we have to we just have to
be civil we just have to be nice we have
to be tolerant we have to don't you I um
don't be so judgey the truth is arrogant
the truth is arrogant and the truth
makes claims it asserts things we're in
a culture that doesn't want to assert
anything we don't want to say I think we
don't want to say I believe we don't
want to state facts we just want to say
I feel like we want to distance
ourselves well maybe that's true that's
your truth that's not my truth sometimes
you've got to stand up for the truth and
sometimes the truth is going to push you
to a such a sense of assertiveness that
you've got to punch Arius in the face
I'm not advocating violence but I am
advocating assertiveness I am advocating
rhetorical violence if there were such a
thing I am advocating standing by your
guns we're seeing a play out right now
in this government shut down this
Christmas government shut down President
Trump is there he's gonna stick by his
guns or he won't have stood for the main
central promise of his campaign is he
gonna stick by it or are we gonna get it
classic cliffhanger from from President
Trump we'll see what happens in the New
Year have a Merry Christmas have a Happy
New Year
I'll see in 2019 I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the
Michael no leo
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you